okay listen it's been pretty dark here
because of the election results and
because of of a lot of what we're going
to be dealing with in the United States
over the next four years let's
transition to talking about instead of
dark politics dark roasts we are ready
now to have your help naming the david
pakman show coffee blends I've mentioned
this a couple of times we're going to
have to coffee blends okay one will be
for drip coffee so if you have like a
regular coffee machine or a French press
or a chemex or any of the machines were
just a regular coffee machine we will
have one david pakman show coffee roast
or drip coffee machines for those of you
like me who are more into espresso we
are going to also have an espresso roast
david pakman show coffee option I now
I'm going to present to you the
finalists for the names for these 2
roasts and then I'll tell you what the
next step is okay I don't know yet what
I'm just taking names and then we'll
figure out which one will be espresso
which one will be drip coffee some will
be more obvious because of the names the
the voting poll is up at david
pakman.com ok so let's take a look at
the options for our coffee roasts here's
one that I kind of like it's simple but
I like it instead of the david pakman
show the david pakman Joe of course Joe
a nickname for coffee the david pakman
joe progressively percolated
progressively percolated any number of
beans referring to this phrase that I at
one point not consciously overused and
now I over use just as a goof any number
of beans freedom of the press freedom of
the press free speech still drips I like
that this one's kind of tongue-in-cheek
but I I do like it she'll spray so this
is referring of course to me being a
shill for all sorts of different stuff
I'm a Hillary chill I'm a Zionist shill
I'm a social justice warrior shill who
knows what I'm shielding for these days
but in any case she'll spray so
progressive a wake up call progressive
wake up call and lastly Patriots
repellent hate riete repellent vote vote
vote okay david pakman.com
at if you scroll down on the right side
of the website you will see the pole and
you can select two options because we
are going to have to roast you can
select your favorite two options and
while you're there the david pakman show
shop is back up t-shirts hoodies bumper
stickers sweatshirts all that stuff is
available of course the calendar as well
you go to david pakman.com and you click
the shop button at the top and get your
calendars as well so the process pat is
we've opened the pole up once we have
our winners i will come back announce
them and then we are also going to
source the label designs from the
audience once we have the names i love
when the audience is involved in
designing stuff that we do we will
actually take label designs from the
audience for the custom labels that will
go on the coffee i think this is a great
thing to distract a little bit from the
disaster that is the state of American
politics right now yeah absolutely and
I'm glad you can vote for two but are we
going with the popular vote here uh no
we're going electoral oh yeah I don't
know it but what the hell that means
when it comes to voting for coffee but
you know what we are gonna be Alec
totally selecting the results which I
guess just means Pat decides once we get
the vote in we ignore the vote and
patches decides what he wants right is
that the closest thing to the electoral
coffee vote this isn't a democracy
inertia but yes please vote david
packard.com name that coffee and a lot
of people looking forward to this coffee
is a big deal I didn't realize that a
lot of people drink coffee pat you know
Dunkin Donuts every half block in Boston
didn't it didn't relay to me that a lot
of people drink coffee but they do yeah
i mean i'm honestly averaging about 2 to
3 cups a day so I'm certainly on the the
caffeine train